The Big Bang.
No space.
Total darkness.
Nothing. Suddenly the universe sparks into
life.
Really? Surely everyone knows you can't get
something from nothing.
It's really the ultimate question How did the
universe come into being?
And the thing is, we don't want just
everything to come from nothing.
It seems like a trick, but here we are.
We exist. So something must have happened
and we just don't understand the physics of
it yet.
This is one of the big open questions in
cosmology, the origin of the universe.
And I think that people have variously said
stuff like, Oh, the universe has come from
nothing like, Ta.
Da, now there's a universe.
But remember, we don't have data about the
earliest moments of the universe.
We don't know what was going on.
We're struggling in the dark to get insight
into what may have happened before the Big
Bang. That period of apparent nothingness.
Physicists look to empty space.
But does empty really mean there's
absolutely nothing there?
It's not that there's something coming from
nothing, because that old fashioned idea of
nothing just doesn't apply to what we think
of as empty space.
It turns out empty space is far from empty.
The vacuum of space is really a writhing
sea, awash with charged quantum particles and
electromagnetic fields.
The vacuum of space itself can be a very
dynamic thing.
Matter can spontaneously appear out of the
vacuum and then spontaneously annihilate.
The vacuum is full of particles and
antiparticles that are whizzing into
existence and then disappearing, colliding
with each other.
Space is full of virtual particles popping in
and out of existence.
And there's no question that they're real.
Their effects are absolutely visible.
We can see them.
In extreme physics, things can get strange.
Maybe nothing is something after all.
If empty space contains particles that
apparently come from nothing, Could some sort
of similar process have triggered the Big
Bang?
The quantum vacuum itself can randomly,
spontaneously, without any input, just
have a lot of energy, perhaps enough energy
to spark something that we would call a big
bang.
There are many speculative theories about the
origin of the universe, but is its sudden
appearance out of nothingness the only trick
it pulled off?
It also made matter from energy.
The universe is full of galaxies, stars,
planets and comets.
Where did they all come from?
According to the Big Bang narrative from one
tiny dot.
When the universe began, there was actually
no room for matter at all.
The temperature was so high, the spaces were
so compressed that matter couldn't exist.
So how did the universe manage to become full
of matter?
In the primeval atom.
There was no room for matter, but it was
crammed full of energy.
And as Einstein tells us, all we need to
create matter is energy.
According to E equals MC squared, energy and
matter are interchangeable.
Einstein taught us with special relativity
that energy and matter are two sides of the
same coin.
You can convert matter into energy by, say,
blowing something up.
The most fearsome example of converting
matter into energy was the atomic bomb
developed in the 1940s.
But with the big bang, this process was
reversed.
Energy created matter.
Matter that expanded out and out to fill a
whole universe.
And in cosmic terms, the universe where
matter would develop grew remarkably fast.
Right after the universe was born, it had an
unbelievable growth spurt, basically going
from being a toddler to a teenager in the
single tick of a clock.
How could the universe get so big so quickly?
If we believe the Big Bang story, it appears
to have broken one of the most fundamental
laws of physics.
Did the early universe really grow faster
than the speed of light?
Parts of the universe that are now separated
by 93 billion light years once had the same
cosmic zip code.
To have expanded so quickly, inflation must
have broken one of the fundamental rules of
physics.
We all know that one rule the universe sticks
to all the time is that nothing can travel
faster than the speed of light.
So how can we possibly say that the universe
expanded faster than the speed of light?
But inflation says the universe expands into
nothingness.
There was no outside of the universe.
The universe was everything.
So space itself was inflating and space can
move as fast as it wants.
You can't go faster than the speed of light
through space, but space itself is allowed to
stretch and expand as fast as it wants, and
that's what our universe is doing.
The idea of inflation smooths out the
universe in kind of a peculiar way.
You can kind of think of it as having a
sheet with a lot of wrinkles in it.
And if you take that sheet and snap it
really hard, those wrinkles very suddenly
flatten out.
The theory of inflation is one of the
craziest sounding ideas in the history of
science. So crazy that it might just be
right.
Inflation helps us to understand the
inexplicable.
But there's a problem.
We don't know what triggered or powered
inflation.
The inflationary universe idea imagines that
the universe was suffused with some kind of
ultra dense energy at early times, something
that pushed the universe apart.
What caused there to be that hot, expanding
stuff?
We have to be humble and acknowledge that we
don't know for sure.
But whatever started it, inflation was over
in a split second.
It didn't last very long.
And this is difficult to understand.
How did inflation stop?
We don't know. We got nothing.
Folks. Well, we got some things, but it's
tough.
It's tough.
But has the process of inflation really
stopped?
One radical theory proposes if the force
called inflation kick started the expansion
of one universe, then why not another?
And another and another?
Is inflation creating a whole series of new
universes?
Is there a multiverse?